JoJo Siwa did oopsie
DrDisrespect did an oopsie
And PewDiePie - no OOPSIES
wooooooooooooooooopsie
Good evening. I'm Poppy Moria, and welcome to Mary Ham News!
Our first story comes from JoJo Siwa. JoJo Siwa is a Youtuber with over almost 10 million subscribers.
HELLO MY GOOD FRIENDS AND WELCOME BACK TO THE BIG KIDS. I'M PIP!
Why does this exist? Well, it turns out that in JoJo Siwa's...
...products it was contaminated
for the second time with Asbestos!
WHAT!
(You never played Tuber Simulator?!)
JoJo Siwa has products that cause cancer
WHAT! Not only does her content cause cancer, now her products do as well!!
JoJo Siwa was like my pillar of trust.
How could she break it like this!? What the frick JoJo Siwa, I trusted you!
I've always said: JoJo Siwa, I can trust no matter what!
I buy all my merch and makeup products from her.
But for those of you don't know: Asbestos, it's usually found in fiberglassing like isolation of houses.
i n s u l a t i o n
It's very not good to breathe in that stuff. That can give you cancer and other illnesses.
Very bad thing. Causing cancer to your fans, not good... Okay.
So she'll release this apology video-
APOLOGY VIDEO TIME! YAY!
*Happiness Noises*
Let's watch.
*Sigh Of Doom*
Are you serious? Are you freaking serious?
This motherf-
You do not give off that...
...You do not have the right to give off that smirk.
JoJo, all right, and don't get me started with the ironic sigh. Le sigh.
I'm getting very angry!
You know nothing says,
genuine apology video like disabling the comments and uploading it on your second channel. Yay!
Let's make sure as few people as possible know about this!
JoJo: I can't do that. x2  I was gonna start this video all serious and dramatic, but
That's not who I am. That's not what this video is about. It's just-
Pewds: This video makes me....
This video is just pure pain to watch so I'll just skip to the end.
JoJo: You can get a refund, at no matter what it is, if it's used, if it's unused, you can get a full refund.
Pewds: Oh, so I can still use it. It has asbestos in it, but I can still use it. That's great!
I got asbestos for free! (and that's a great price)
Wow, that's so nice. Thank You, JoJo Siwa thank youuuu!
To be fair, play Devil's Advocate.
Maybe this is one of those things where-
God I'm trying to think. *laughs*
Maybe this is one of those things where it sounds bad, but it really is not that big of a deal?
This is the only way I can defend this!
I don't know and I don't care to look into it, because I'm Mary Ham and research? That's for pussies!
*clap* next! *clap* news!
Update! Update news!! Get excited for Update news!!
Tfue versus Faze Clan drama update. Yay! I really want to know more about this, please tell us! Yes, I will, I will. ;))
Okay, calm down. Tfue's lawyer has spoken out-
-in an interview. Previously what we know about the faze clan vs
Tfue lawsuit was the fact that faze clan kept saying: "Oh we tried to just give him like an updated contract (why is there a p?),
but he just said no, he doesn't want to be part of faze. He just like he doesn't want to be part of it
He- he's so unreasonable. Like, why does he not just...
...negotiate with us?"
Well, apparently as it turns out, through T-fue's lawyers that they did they try to give a legal version of the contract to them-
which Faze Clan then...
adjusted so much in the sense that it became illegal again.
Faze Clan was presented with the contract Turner would accept.
It was, you know, as close to a legal contract and you can get, but
apparently, that wasn't good enough for them and they decided to, uh...
Mark up about half of it, get rid of about half of it, put in their own provisions;
Which, again, made it illegal once again.
Obviously, this is interesting because it changes sort of what was the dynamic of what was said.
But at the same time, what their version of the conduct could have been easily as unreasonable,
to Faze Clan as Faze Clan's contract to T-Fue. So it could be whatever. Yeah in the end
it could it doesn't even matter.
Another point that was interesting that was brought up was these sixty thousand dollars that Faze Clan
had only taken from T-fue and that was it, that's all they'd taken. But the lawyer brings up-
Well, he's actually brought them in so much more money just from being in Faze.
Thousand dollar figure as to what they made off him. It's disingenuous!
I mean, you realize how much money Faze Clan is making by
having Turner as part of its team? How much advertising
they're selling? How many sponsorships that they obtain because Turner was part of their team?
It's almost laughable to think that they are saying that they took
sixty thousand dollars from him and that's it. When they've made
millions of dollars.
Okay. Alright. It's a good point, right?
That's why Faze wants to have T-fue part of Faze to begin with so that they can make money...
of his clout, his epic fortnite clout!
Smash like if you like fortnite!
But then again, if he makes him that much money through brand deals then
why the hell did he only make sixty
thousand from it, right? Or what's 20%? I mean math, help me. Sixty times X-
X times-
X times zero.
Twenty...
It's three hundred thousand. That's my math.
*Disappointed laughter*
T-fue's only made three hundred thousand through brand deals from Faze Clan.
Alright, next!
Deji!
Deji versus KSI drama. Now, this has been some of the hottest drama in a very long time! *evil laugh*
Like, no- no one cares about this. Even me trying to figure it out. I'm like, okay. All right. Well... *dumb laughter*
Deji uploaded a video yesterday or two days ago. It's very emotional (here we go again)
YoU kNOw WhaT, I'M TiREd oF iT
iF yOu UNdeRstOod wHaT I wAs gOing ThROugh
ThEn yOu WoUld UNdeRstAnd, aLrIght!?
bUt PEople HaVe tO "Stutters"
sO MuCh LyINg aBoUt yOU
Okay, so how did we end up here?
Well, let me summarise for you!
Instead of watching, what, like five hours of content?
Three weeks ago, *stutters* Deji, KSI 's brother,
uploaded a video saying that he's tired of being seen as the bad guy and he uploaded this video called "bye", and he's like:
Uhh, my brother is not that great. Okay...
The main gist of the video was that he felt like his brother didn't stand up for him,
his brother didn't have his back, and that he's done a lot of shady stuff as well.
Have your back? No matter what?
Family sticks by you.
Then KSI responded to this video:
I was here for you
Whether we're on good terms or bad terms. Whenever you message me, I always reply Dej
I want you to succeed in everything you do. But Dej, man,
you have to communicate with me!
To me, this video seemed pretty genuine.
He addressed almo- I think all the issues that Deji brought up about...
the girl drama that happened.
Apparently, KSI slept with a girl that Deji liked.
Some drama that happened during Christmas who (Demonetisation) cares? That Deji...
is always getting punched in his videos, or something like that.
and they do respond to saying, okay moving on great great
Thank God just solve this privately like why was this video made to begin with?
I would be a lot more inclined to pick deji's side in this situation
If this original video didn't have a bunch of mid-rolls on it
It's a 45-minute video
very much in the same style as the Tati call out James Charles video that was gaining so much traction
If it wasn't for these two things
I would be more inclined to believe the deji's intention with just wanting to stand up for himself
He keeps saying that I'm not attacking KSI
I am just standing up for myself that my intention was not to attack him
But you are bringing up a lot of things about your brother to make him look bad
You don't have to do that to defend yourself. Not all of it
Is that way but a lot of it is you can stab someone and say I'm not trying to hurt you
Well, that doesn't change the fact then deji uploads a fourth video wearing the exact same outfit
What have you been tuned for the past two weeks deji?
Yo what's up guys it is deji
Oh my god
"Swedish Laughter"
In this video Deji says that he has huge evidence saying that KSI lied about the girl thing because KSI said
KSI said he didn't know who the girl he slept with
was actually someone his brother knew. Oh my god,
he straight up lied
I'm gonna show you some huge evidence that will just make you question the whole of my brother's video
I didn't even know she knew you I don't even remember your name even being mentioned
For all I knew she was just a girl that I met at a concert. I didn't even see her in any of your videos
And then these are his texts
Okay, These are his texts
You read them for yourselves
So this is KSI saying that he knew the girl was on his channel
But that doesn't prove that he knew that they were together. But then again
KSI, look at this. I have evidence.
Never remember your name even being mentioned for all I knew
he touch his nose
That's like a classic example of lying ksi liar confirmed.
This happened what three years ago two two years ago is 2016
I don't remember what I did yesterday
Help me, please. It just seems so stupid all of this. Did you guys not listen in my tati video?
Stop bringing private things into public then that he showed It get's so
Bizarre that he shows a the text message between her and this girl because he thought she gave him an STD
Oh, this is someone else sorry
Deji he is writing fu man to a girl
Made me sick you dumb F. How are you gonna meet me then tell me you're sick. Honestly F yourself
I ain't meeting you anymore. I don't trust you. You could have given me an STD
Dumb B word. I'm sorry, sad face sad face
I only started feeling ill that day when I was on the way up sad face, sad face f off
You're a real piece of sh
Do you have an STD cuz I swear what of course I don't good sad face go away
What the hell is this? I met this girl, right she did she had a cold. I didn't know she had a cold
I literally had like a cold the next day and I thought she gave me an STD I was pissed
That's why I said all the Mean sh I said
What the hell is this
Oh My god, I got a cold
I thought you had an STD then it gets very emotional and very intense
AND THEN THAT GIRL, THE STUPID B... STUPID GIRL
(Pewds: Hoho, he almost said it)
HAS THE AUDACITY TO MAKE A VIDEO SAYING SHE'S CLEARING THE AIR,
WHEN YOU KNOW WHAT YOU DID! YOU F~~~~D UP MASSIVELY!
Despite deji's flaws. I do like him in a way. He's... he has... He has some likeable qualities, okay
I hate to see him like this. I think this has clearly gone too far. Deji...
Please take a break. You'll be fine. It's time to take a break from YouTube. This is...
It's not a good idea. In one way, you know, he's the one that made the first video,
he's the one that started all this out of nowhere and it shows again how bad of an idea is to bring these
private matters into the public eye, a lot of people seem to think like
"Oh yeah, people just do all this crazy stuff to start drama online and like it's gonna be epic they get so much views - "
Yes, they get views from it
But clearly it's taken a massive mental toll on Deji and I do feel him for that and I think I hope he realises
To just stop this no one cares who's right and wrong at this point. I don't. Just... it's time to drop it
I will not be talking about this anymore. This is just stupid at this point
I think it shows of... It's a fatal flaw of YouTube with how...
You know, numbers start dropping and you feel like you have to do something, and then at the end, was it worth it?
I don't think so.
Next news doctor disrespect did something disrespectful
WHAT! unbelievable?
So doctor disrespect did an IRL stream on the E3 floor.
He was very much in character making fun of people at the site
*Doc Being Unleashing his inner child at E3 Colorised with arcade music in the background*
Then doctor disrespect did the unthinkable he had very HARD poopoo and needed to go and
Pewds.EXE is not Responding
Make mud pies
Diarrhea Place?
"Doc Running at the speed of light to diarrhea place"
And he filmed inside the bathroom, so here's how that footage looked like
What is this?????
MASSIVE OoPSIE
Ladies a jump I gotta take a diarrhea grab that
MASSIVE OoPSIE CONTINUED
This cause doctor disrespect
Of getting banned from twitch. That's right everybody. So it is against the Community Guidelines
I think on twitch website it says that sharing content that violates another reasonable expectation of privacy
From for example streaming from a private space without permission.
Should this doctor disrespect been banned? Yes. I don't think anyone
is arguing against, he clearly went against the rules I and
That's just how it is.
I've seen a lot of people's picking some sort of moral high-ground of going "Oh, I can't believe, I can't believe
doctor disrespect did this!" obviously I understand that's people want bathrooms to be a private space and
That that should not be violated. I'd get it at the same time. I don't see the big deal (laughs)
It's sort of like the mean with boys locker room
What do people think happened in the boys locker? What if someone saw someone's penis?
I have never seen a penis in a boys locker room or a
Men's bathroom. Okay, unless you specifically go slow and you're not gonna receive some peanut peepee
A lot of people have been saying well there was a kid. There was a kid in one of the urinals. Oh
Well checkmate liberals kids aren't allowed at e3. Maybe you should try and ban him instead, huh?
Oh, it's illegal to film in a bathroom. Okay?
All right, but let's look at the law number of six four and seven which everyone brings up. This is the one everyone talks
It's illegal. It's illegal. Okay. Well, what does it say?
Privacy: A person who looks through a hole or opening, into, or otherwise views, by means of any instrumentality, including, but not limited to, a periscope, telescope, binoculars, camera, motion picture camera, camcorder, or mobile phone, the interior of a bedroom, bathroom, changing room, fitting room, dressing room, or tanning booth, or the interior of any other area in which the occupant has a reasonable expectation of privacy, with the intent to invade the privacy of a person or persons inside. This subdivision does not apply to those areas of a private business used to count currency or other negotiable instruments.
With the intent, was it doctor disrespect intent to invade the privacy of a person in there
I think that's arguable. Maybe-- I'm not a lawyer so I have no idea what I'm talking about from this footage of this
It's just following him into the bathroom stall. It's not trying to show other people
This is what I got about out of it. Was it a bad idea?
Absolutely. Should he have gotten banned? I guess so, that are - those are the rules
Was this the worst thing that has ever happened? I don't think so
That is not for me to say "I think other people should do this", I'm just looking at the context of this
I don't think it's that big of a deal to act so outraged about okay
It seems more like people are insecure about their schlongs being shown on camera for some reason and me, Mary ham, don't care!
No insecurities about sling songs. Our final notes comes from pita who made this tweet. Love the new hash tag Pokemon Rule. Ooh
Great. Well, my new favorite Pokemon is ruined. Thanks Peter. They have a special message for all their future trainers
I'm not your ruler sweater. This is a meme template waiting to happen. And of course Shadow the Hedgehog (small mental breakdown)
Unbelievable my wool grows back. Anyone is welcome to take my wool sheeps have to be sheared. They don't shed like most animals
Shearing doesn't hurt them at all. They enjoy it. Well done Peter. Well done that
Was it for all the oopsies this week, PewDiePie, no oopsies, smash like, subscribe. Check out the merch guys, very epic
We got the new Tsuki merch. That's right. We launched beanies in the summer. What are you?
What are you not a hipster? Check out represent.com support the channel?
namaste
Limited time epic lateness we have t-shirts now.
WHAT!
YOU NEVER PLAYED TUBER SIMULATOR?! PFFFT!
You know it's... Fun, right?
I'm not supposed to give my opinion... But give it a try, and then you can tell me if it's good or not.
Not convinced yet? Okay. I'll cut you a deal. The game is available... for free. And that's a great price!
(EPIC THEME TUNE HAHA SERIOUSLY TRY IT)